understanding iido part two the Mixed
Martial Arts
Revolution so as I said in the last
video uh there's many contexts to
martial arts when use word martial art
martial arts is a large field it's a
field that includes uh unarmed fighting
armed fighting all kinds of different
weapons all kinds of fighting in
different terrains and environments
surprise situations multiple attackers
there's lots involved when you when you
say the word martial art however in this
country or probably in most of the
modern world when we say the word
martial art we're really referring to
one context only which is uh unarmed
oneon-one
uh this is a problem when you're trying
to try and understand a martial art like
iido because iido wasn't designed for
this context uh this context wasn't
really even considered much um when you
look at the techniques that were chosen
for iido so what mixed martial arts did
is they helped us really really
understand what this one context that we
think a lot about is and what what's
important to that context so and that
context being unarmed one on one so
we're talking about guys in a controlled
situation where there's someone making
sure everyone follows the rules um
they're not going to be using any
weapons the people are of approximately
the same size uh you know a lot of lot
of controls going into this one
situation this makes for great
competition right so um fights are
boring when there's one big strong guy
who's always destroying someone else um
fights are much more exciting when when
the people are evenly matched and that's
what you see a lot in modern mixed
martial arts is this uh desire to make
things equal and similar um in iido we
don't really look at that at all so
trying to understand iido from this
perspective is impossible and while
mixed martial arts gave us a lot it
doesn't really help us understand iido a
lot of times you'll see people from the
mixed martial arts world or sport
competitive World want to take iido and
put it into their context and then see
if iido is any good uh so for example we
have an MMA fight you tell an Niko guy
okay we'll go into the MMA ring and see
if uh your your stuff is valid against
this other guy who's a real good MMA uh
Fighter um this is not fair and not
reasonable um for example if I took an
MMA fighter and I took him to a a a
modern war situation and I had a soldier
who's been training for years in combat
situations I said okay you two go after
each other and hear some guns um the MMA
fighter is almost certainly going to
lose to a seasoned War veteran um and
when I say that story you you quickly
say oh well of course but if we took the
the war veteran and we put him in a ring
with an MMA fighter he's going to lose
and that's also correct because each
person in their own context is doing
very very well they're they're very
capable within their own context so if
you take a person outside of their
context and put them in someone else's
context they're not going to do very
good but within their own context
they'll do very very well so if you take
iido and you put it in a one-on-one
unarmed situation you're not going to
get good results D people are not going
to do well you're never going to study
uh iido and become a master boxer you're
never going to study iido and become a
master wrestler or mixed martial artist
it doesn't work like that you're going
to study iido and become good at what
aikido's context is and all the
techniques within iido are designed for
that context so the next part we're
going to talk about what aikido's
context is and why and how that will
help us really understand and be able to
narrow in and become better at our
martial art I'm Christopher Hein thanks
for
watching